the graph of the function f is shown
below
what is the input value other than
negative five for which f of x is equal
to f of negative five
so we have our x-axis we have our y-axis
and then in blue they've graphed y
equals f of x so for example when x is
equal to 1
f of x when y is going to be equal to f
x that's what this graph is is f of x is
equal to one when
x is equal to seven f of seven we see is
equal to five when x is equal to nine we
see that f of nine is equal to six
so what is the input value other than
negative 5 for which f of x is equal to
f of negative 5. so let's see if x is
equal to negative 5
f of negative 5 is we move up here to
the graph it is equal to 4 because this
once again this is the graph y is equal
to f of x
so the y coordinate here this is what f
of x this is what f of negative 5 is
equal to so f of negative 5 is equal to
4. so where else does that happen so
let's see let's just move horizontally
to the right that happens here as well
so what input do we have to give what's
the x coordinate here to get y is equal
to f of x or f of x is equal to 4 right
over here well we see the x coordinate
is also 4. so this tells us that f 4 is
equal to 4 which is the same thing as f
of negative 5.
so when x is 4 the function takes on the
same value as when x is negative five so
x
equals four
and we're done